bienvenue
à mi gentille
j'aime tellement ça
Isabelle vittary et mon modèle dans ce
domaine magnifique
[Musique]
au premier deuxième troisième degré on
passe tout en bon moment depuis peu je
suis prof de chenille donc je suis
chemise et j'ai ouvert l'école la
chemise school Academy c'est de la
chenille synchronisée
les plus ambitieuses possibles
[Musique]
on se mélange aux autres où on peut se
coucher tout le monde a les compétences
et c'est juste un moment de communion et
de joie entre les êtres humains
[Musique]
c'est la voiture Caroline Loeb c'est la
ouate et le lobe c'est l'oreille voilà
et ben il y a Kenji man il y a du beau
monde voilà c'est un trou
de TF1
4 autres débats sont en cours car la vie
de cabinet s'ouvre Elisabeth borne
serait un cauchemar alors on savait déjà
que la première ministre était surnommée
par certains méchantas qu'est-ce que tu
la gardes pour ce soir je pense pourquoi
ah mais tu fais comme tu veux enfin je
t'ai fait une remarque à midi donc tu
restes comme ça tu vas faire un service
soir comme ça en tant que j'ai pas
encore mon tablier ce qu'il y a personne
mais ouais
c'est un style c'est un style à la corde
comme ça vous vous appelez comment
Michel Michel alors où vous êtes le
produit ménager dont on tirera le nom
peut-être ou vous faites du rugby où
vous faites de la muscu beaucoup de
musculation vous pouvez les d'où alors
je viens depuis tout dans le 92 je pense
que quand on vous voit on n'a pas envie
de vous en rapporter
quand il n'avait plus le choix il se
retrouvait devant la porte prenait une
profonde inspiration et lançait allez
pour la France et puis les entrées
[Musique]
dans la bouche
[Applaudissements]
pour l'éternité
[Musique]
le G braillé très très fort très très
familièrement
oui alors Isabelle Balkany perdu et je
vous ai fait une liste c'est une liste
très hété Bachar al-Assad Winston
Philippe Pétain et alors qu'il l'a
encore c'est là où c'est paradoxal bah
Vladimir Poutine le débat est toujours
là la cigogne piégée par une canette de
Coca-Cola a été sauvé en Saône-et-Loire
grâce au bon coup d'œil d'un groupe
d'enfance sortie scolaire l'animal
affaibli qui ne s'était pas alimentée
depuis une semaine a été capturé par les
pompiers le sort de cette cigogne avait
été relayée partout sur internet repéré
par un agriculteur elle a tout de même
parcouru plus de 150 km à vol d'oiseau
avec le bec coincé une mésaventure qui
nous rappelle de ne surtout pas jeter
ses déchets dans la nature j'en peux
plus tu es trop chaud dans l'eau c'est
pas du tout dur c'est très supportable
par contre en dehors de l'eau c'est
suffocant et de mémoire je serai rare de
voir ça encore
un mois de juin à partir de 9h le matin
ça y est c'est déjà dur la glacière
obligatoire
c'est pas évident mais on se fait c'est
une quinzaine de degrés au dessus des
normales du mois de juin en Corse c'est
une blague tu n'as pris que les entrées
en fait tu prends que l'entrée qui amène
l'entrée après tu vas retourner voir la
table
et après je fais tous les je peux en
passer une ou pas déjà celle qui est là
elle est bonne j'entends bien que ce
soit un débat mais si tu n'écoutes
jamais mon propos tu pourras jamais me
répondre
j'ai envie de mettre des fois des boules
Quies tellement que c'est énorme mes
cheveux tombe c'est pour ça que je les
ai coupés depuis donc voilà
dès qu'on est pas d'accord toi tu es un
vrai de Macron dès qu'on a pas d'accord
il faut faire plein de verse fermer sa
bouche je ferme pas ma bouche mon grand
sens figuré le produit tu prendras je me
servirai contre toi c'est du jamais vu
les amis
c'est du jamais vu c'est de l'inédit
de l'inéd
it